on a longtemps cru que l'europe est et
lieu de naissance de l'art rupestre
grâce à des découvertes comme les
grottes ornées de lascaux ou de chauvet
en france or des travaux récents menés
par un chercheur québécois confirme que
ce type d'art préhistorique existait
aussi en asie du sud est
à la même époque peut-être même avant
[Musique]
[Rires]
elles se cachent pour fin fond de la
jungle indonésienne
dans des décors sauvages près de petits
villages isolés à flanc de montagne dans
des grottes et des abris de roche
calcaire
ce sont des peintures millénaire parmi
les plus vieilles du monde
des témoignages uniques de notre passé
des découvertes inédites qui oblige les
experts à réécrire une partie de
l'histoire humaine
les gens c'est comme s'ils sont eux ils
me parlent en fait on a vraiment un
certain d'intimité et c'est quelqu'un il
ya 4000 ans il a fait exprès affirmé me
sens mais là et qui a soufflé de leurs
crampons au tour donc donc c'est comme
si ça nous parle encore aujourd'hui
quinze minutes plus tard
l'archéologue québécois maxime aubert
explore ces grottes depuis 2013 à la
recherche des origines de l'art avec ses
collègues il ya découvert des endroits
fabuleux qui n'ont rien à envier aux
hauts lieux de l'art pariétal qu'on
connaît en europe
la différence c'est le nombre de grottes
répertoriés chaque année on trouve un
peu plus 12e de grottes avec des
peintures c'est vraiment partout d'un
costaud qu'on regarde on trouve en fait
des grottes avec des peintures partout
partout partout
c'est vraiment incroyable et moi ce que
je trouve encore plus incroyable si par
exemple en france on trouverait quelque
un autre grotte chauvet ou un autre
grotte par exemple lascaux ce serait une
énorme découvert par un autre grotte
comme ça mais en indonésie à ce loisir
on en trouve des douzaines par année
dans l'île de sulawesi aussi appelé
célèbes et dans celle de bornéo
il a entrepris d'étudier des peintures
préhistoriques découverte dans quinze
grotte différentes
[Musique]
pour mieux comprendre leurs origines des
échantillons ont été récoltés sur les
peintures dans certaines grottes l'eau
qui ruisselle à former des couches de
calcite sur les parois grâce à une
technique basée sur la décomposition de
certains atomes contenus dans la calcite
le chercheur et ses collègues ont pu
déterminer l'âge approximatif des
peintures la couche de peinture a tant
que tel à peu près de date et donc nous
serons assez de trouver ces des
échantillons de calcite qui se sont
formés soit au-dessus d'appétit aux
sociétés l'avant donc si on a des
champions qui est au dessus de la couche
de peinture ça ça me savait donner une
date minimum et si on en dessous ça nous
donne une date maximum par contre ça
c'est très rare en fait donc des décide
de peinture et antonia on a retrouvé
beaucoup mais avec des échantillons
dessus il y en a pas beaucoup
les résultats de ces analyses sont
saisissants
sur cette paroi d'une grotte de bornéo
on aperçoit trois représentations
couleur ocre de ce qui ressemble à des
bovins typique de la région
l'un d'eux a au moins quarante mille ans
c'est la plus vieille peinture
figurative connu à ce jour
cette empreinte de main en négatif a le
même âge
elle se trouve à sulawesi elle est aussi
vieille et même un peu plus que d'autres
empreintes du même genre découverte
ailleurs dans le monde juste à côté
cette peinture d'un babiroussa une sorte
de phacochères local rarement observée
dans la nature de nos jours à au moins
35 mille ans
[Musique]
d'autres oeuvres sont plus récentes en
témoigne leur couleur violette distincte
de l'orangé des peintures plus ancienne
mais elles sont tout aussi unique sur le
plafond de cette grotte de bornéo par
exemple à plusieurs mètres du sol
des gens ont laissé leurs empreintes de
mains en négatif par dizaines ils les
ont décoré comme avec des tatouages et
lison relier entre elles
on dirait une sorte d'arbre généalogique
créé il y à au moins seize mille ans il
relie en fait des mains qui sont
plusieurs retouches avec des mains plus
récente qui après vingt et un mille 1 et
puis aussi ses mails en avaient ils sont
joints à des mains d'enfants aussi en
mauvais donc peut-être que ça ça montre
que les gens à ce moment alors est au
courant de leur passé leur présent leur
futur autre trouvaille qui date à peu
près de la même époque
ces petits personnages de quelques
centimètres de haut sont souvent
présentés en petits groupes
coiffé de ce qui ressemble à une
empreinte digitale
on n'a aucune information à propos des
gens qui ont fait ces deux styles l'on a
fait de bien sûr mans series donc c'est
super c'est pour ça que cette année donc
on va commencer à faire à faire des
fouilles archéologiques dont on veut
savoir en fait c'est qui en fait qu'il
n'ya fait ça qu'est ce qu'ils mangeaient
qu'elle soit 12,6 en fait utilisé tout
ça et puis peut-être qu'on va pour
trouver des raisonnements humains ayant
fait donc ils sont les chansons on va
peut-être fait l'adn et puis peut-être
qu'on va pouvoir trouver city qui a fait
ses ses peintures l'homme et à ce moment
là donc présentement en outre l'idée la
découverte de l'âge vénérable de
certaines de ses peintures indonésienne
correspond à ce que l'on connaît de la
présence humaine dans la région dans la
grotte denis à à bornéo
on a découvert dans les années 50 un
crâne de mots sa pièce vieux lui aussi
de près de quarante mille ans mais les
peintures rupestres pourrait être encore
plus vieille selon les analyses de
maxime aubert et son équipe
le bovin de bornéo par exemple a au
minimum 40 milan et au maximum 50 2000
[Musique]
on sait aussi que l'homme moderne était
à sumatra ya à peu près à peu près 60 65
mille ans et puis l'image pour pour
l'australie en fait on sait que l'homme
moderne est arrivé en australie et à peu
près en 60 70 millions donc il pourrait
arriver en australie il faut qu'ils
passent par là et il faut qu'ils passent
par par l'asie du sud est
ces découvertes remettre en cause ce que
l'on croyait connaître de la naissance
de l'art jusqu'à présent les plus
anciennes grottes ornées connu était en
europe
on croyait donc que c'était la cave est
immergée ce moyen d'expression
témoin d'une pensée abstraite et
symbolique
il ya beaucoup de gens qui disaient bien
vu qu'on a juste trouvé les pinceaux
comme ça en europe qu'on a pu dater
si c'est quand que l'homme moderne et
est arrivé en europe que l'oeil est
devenu collectivement moderne mêlant
conte adapté des peintures semblable à
l'autre bout du monde est à peu près 40
mille ans donc on peut dire que le ben
non on fait donc c'est comment pas vrai
donc ça c'était vraiment un point de vue
le qui était très très heureux centre et
donc on peut vraiment montré que quand
le modem est arrivé aux deux extrémités
de l'eurasie en fait était était moderne
[Musique]
de cette conclusion découle une nouvelle
question homo sapiens c'est une mise à
peindre aux deux extrémités de la
planète à peu près en même temps ou
peigne est il déjà avant de quitter son
berceau africain des dizaines de
milliers d'années plus tôt à ce jour la
réponse est un tableau inachevé